[musique]
score
ont longtemps été des résidents du sud-ouest historique
les anciennes terres russes s'appelaient
russe et orthodoxe
chats et
[musique]
puis 12 kilomètres de parcloses en réserve bm
pashki et qui sont shawnee rublik
ce n'est pas clair la gloire de l'ukraine
tout est clair différent dire bonjour
le mot clairière à
un
puis opérateur
de nos camarades, dont les parents ne sont pas
seuls collègues amis anciens collègues
mais aussi les parents sont connectés depuis navi
liens familiaux par le sang
bravo on broie juste ça et
Je voulais t'attendre
attrapé des nafs russes dans notre sous-sol
cour avec des mitrailleuses avec tout ce qu'il militaire
crêpe de timurov
comment va-t-elle si mal
les couples ukrainiens peuvent
est allé chercher un pro du tram pressé et goûté
Fedorov
Je veux aussi donner la meilleure note
actions de soldats et d'officiers russes
ils agissent avec courage
professionnellement
héroïquement
s'effondrer les garçons s'effondrer
vous pouvez ramener en Russie et vous
mange où tu vas
votre tâche d'unité
tu as rencontré à cette époque un ancêtre
cintreuses
[musique]
heureux de l'ukraine
pour quelle raison
passé
tu penses que je refuse pour le plaisir 5
peut se dérouler sans problème et a décidé de ne pas attendre
tandis que 6 brut s'ils baisent la veille
moi je le protégerai jusqu'à
et le char est débordé, oui, c'est la rose de la Russie
sokolov pour un couple
les enfants seront utiles dans le ménage
[musique]
pour jersey nous jusqu'à ce qu'elle veuille van et
voici martynyuk
comme un moustique effrayé
trois réservoirs et et et
alors mousse de peau ou les gars vous êtes biélorusses
qu'ils pourraient rentrer à la maison pour du poison
qui est ukrainien je vous suggère
déposer nos [ __ ] d'armes jusqu'à ce que nous
viens tu nay frappe et fais du lobby
c'est-à-dire que j'habite ici
Oh
[musique]
voici une éperlan
plus probablement shusha reviendra
marina mauvais sur
les pluies d'oies reculent
mains étroitement ramadan et laisser leur place
des pantalons
de personnes